- [Narrator] This is the Hercules Beetle,
one of the largest insects on earth.
The Hercules Beetle is named
for its incredible strength.
It can lift and carry
loads 850 times heavier
than its own weight.
The most distinguishing characteristic
of the Hercules Beetle
is the horn-like pincers on its head.
Only male beetles have
this intimidating feature,
and it is used as a formidable weapon
in the battle for mating rights.
The horns are usually about
a third of their body length,
but have been known to grow even longer.
Hercules Beetles are found
in Central and South America,
and in the West Indies,
and feed predominantly
on rotting wood as larvae,
and fruit as adults.
In spite of its strength
and size, the Hercules Beetle
is a threatened species in many countries.
Much of its natural habitat
has been lost to deforestation,
and its populations are suffering.
This is the Hercules Beetle.